it's been a year since I sat down with
the prime minister at number 10 Downey
Street it was Charming it was
challenging it was revealing I wish
sunak made some big promises I know
you'll keep holding to me account
absolutely rest assured let's go through
the report Mr sunak someone else marks
our homework I'm marking your homework
are you mindful your predecessor
couldn't out survive a lettuce K stor
doesn't have a plan you think he's a
terrorist sympathizer the facts speak
for themselves can you say you have
grown the economy
NHS waiting list you failed on that play
can I tell you a personal story yeah
that is a shocking story I've never
understood this Randa thing it seems to
me a completely cack-handed policy why
is this the hill you want to die on but
you don't have an alternative way to
solve that problem I'm not prime
minister when are you going to call the
election pm and the PM round
two